prende a tutti i ragazzi c'è una
caramella
non pensavo fosse così difficile dire
bella a tutti i ragazzi con una
caramella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono farisei fa vj e [ __ ] bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video
sono fatti j
oggi doveri che quindi siamo su happy
meals o mio dio ce l'ho fatta risen pong
partiamo col primo che mi sembra cioè
non è più brutto nel mondo però il
magari livello e figo avrebbe ping pong
star of come lo fa rientrare fa e mai
non sono un esperto di centrare i buchi
e fatemi capire ecco no no no vacanza è
così difficile forse queste sono prove
ragazzi olimpiadi amador mica medaglia
d'oro non chiedetemi come ho fatto non
lo so neanch'io
ok finirà sto livello prima o poi in una
vita perfetto è stato la pelle ed ora
vedete la pelle d'oca a impossible poco
posso fare una roba con steve decente
globale
davanti c'è una qualità di livelli che
giuro sono estasiato jobs takle cosa
fosse un livello decente ce l'abbiano
tipo come se riuscissi a farli tutti
dall'abitudine proprio una figata
pazzesca guardarli come si casa
guardarli con si casa perde luke fa cose
a caso si scorge una gamba è una roba
che bello il problema di tutto questo
ragazzi che sono rimasti incastrati ma
[ __ ] come faccia salire porca
merda perché la gente a normare ragazzi
non lo sapete voi ma sale così le scale
c'è quella bici se ce l'ho fatta ho
vinto ok ok
cosa è successo non lo so neanch'io
ragazzi cellino il sellino
non è colpa sua se muoio dai ma
[ __ ]
sono vivo mi sta aprendo bricolo sto
gioco non lo sto capendo che è successo
alla mia vice spuntato un pene o nella
nostra nissim a perché se è meglio ce la
faccia ma poi muoio in modi che non
capisco nemmeno io c'era è assurda mela
jean perdo la vis comica mezz'ora per
far sta roba non ci credo joris finish
line in triste non sono mai partito così
in happy 3.000 piedi survival come fa un
essere umano non posso impossibile non
posso cadere la 3000 metri sopra vi è
assurda la mia testa è libera
proteste bold che figo o mio dio ragazzi
meglio della macedonia caso cioè non
servono più i frullati ormai ciò sta
roba qua che tritatutto a keyvan anche
le macchine chiamateli stereo anche
l'immondizia
ragazzi io sono razzista contro queste
cose contro l'immondizia contro ivan
bene è stato anche questo è uno dei
livelli cosa vuoi tu pirelli dai cazzo
guai che sono razzista contro i bidoni
se non tv dal caso di picchi
devo capire un attimo perché fanno
queste cose chi che cosa l'abitudine è
la madonna facciamo fanno anno ciak che
già un piede nella fossa poverino quindi
scottano anno farvi capire già faccio
mio dio subito a caso che se tutto
questo sangue sul pavimento non dai
piedi come non facciate a vedere l'uomo
in sedia a rotelle sbiascicate per terra
senza gambe però ok fast scorso è sta
roba vado con steam devo andati sotto
col poco c'è spiegato cosa ho fatto
è un suicidio ma con una partenza
proprio ecco gli incroci latella testa
oggi non c'è manca proprio l'ho lasciato
a casa va a fan culo a minchia niente
l'ho anche preso a calci
[Applauso]
[Musica]
porca di quella tutta o ma incredibile
guarda che non ci sto crede ma come è
possibile allora sentiva è impossibile
rops in comiche un livello tranquillo
era troppo tempo che non faccia una roba
così
ok l'hai presa bravo steve voglio però
fare una roba atletica se riesco non lo
so tipo prince of persia perfetto
perfetto ho mica ce l'ho fatta e
bellissimo quando c'è il nero di sfondo
perché posso tipo togliere lo sfondo è
mettere i pony non è più carino così
ragazzi mi diverto con poco lo so sono
fatto così cosa vi devo dire lo fanno lo
fanno apposta a farsi cosa secondo me
allora perdo la testa anche solo
sfiorando un muro adesso ho preso un
cazzo di pavimento ai 300 all'ora di
testa proprio mi sono fatto niente non è
possibile fonte di sorus michiara
cacciatore di anime
cosa faccio era con la roba ragazzi c'è
qualcuno che grazie ma buongiorno ho
nessuno ha mai detto che non si fanno
gli stampi sul muro con le mani no
perché maleducazione buongiorno pardon è
una persona quando ti dà tutta se stessa
si vede ecco perfetto che cosa si è
lavato la faccia stamattina gli urp
scusami tesoro non volevo però la faccia
me la tengo
ma no cazzo mi avete rotto ma come ho
fatto sei stato tolio che di me ardillo
che lei notato ma iniziando vistola
avanti la faccia oggi meglio di fare un
cazzo invece mai rotto anche la rari
faccio perché non è possibile ma chissà
tizia fatemi capire una cosa ci fa il
padre di uk impiccato
scusami zio è non lo so che sta ri
comodo non volevo giura fantastico
giorno erano ascoltati allora vado dalla
polizia ti denuncio la famiglia e se n'è
andata la [ __ ] brava maniaca si cazzo
di manuel è perché sono un figo 15 a le
maniache che mi perseguita non c'è verso
bellissima per forza all'ascolto di a6 o
catullo anni punti edito così
ma ripensandoci se vuoi ti regalo anche
un anello tanto ti sta bene sul dito
perché la mia testa sta continuando a
girare a caso secret exit se lo faceva
amica mezz'ora level ancora così troller
manco activate mi deve attivare sta roba
per litro level sono fatti tipo livelli
normali solo che ti piano per il culo
continuamente tipo adesso fammi capire
una tv ahinoi cielo saper ma ci avrei
scommesso la vita a vescovi perché
bastarvi di far arrivare un cassetto ok
sto rischiando di prendere un infarto
figlia nostro livello per favore perché
minchia ok mi piace ho fatto no non era
un troll cazzo
no no non ci posso che possa essere mai
più stupido mi sono tolto adesso non
posso più vincere per mi sono tolto
dalla bici fantastico [ __ ] un genio
della settimana facciamo vincere almeno
il casco dai [ __ ] segni be that
ragazzi se maicol dice che possiamo
batterli possiamo batterli bravo michael
arden angelo salta e di te lo posso buca
1 ragazzi buca o non mi dovrei fare lega
spiega teme la sera ho preso una
salsiccia lei
ok michia parchi era michael cia
fottutamente sempre ragione super jump
zip la maxi plasma festa rock
questa è una delle cose più assurde che
abbiamo non è possibile farlo dove vai
magari carico non sa cos'è le scarpe no
mi ha tolto le scarpe no il mio culo il
mio culo no vista stuprando il deretano
ragazzi e va beh non mi toccare non mi
toccare denuncio anche tecniche sembra
che mi segro quando sul serio cioè mio
trim porno ea parte farmi inglobare
della mia taglia erba no come ma cosa
vuole che non c'è sì
oh mio dio mio dio mio che cosa stai
prendisole zio non ho idea di come abbia
fatto ma ok non mi faccio domande
harbour mi sta facendo impressione
giocatore è partito luke ragazzi gli
occhi a partito per la vittoria
non si sa dove andato ma alla vita era
diverso prima dimesso bastardo però va
bene un imporli importante a vincere
vero zio inutile che fai tunz tunz
perché non stai ascoltando un cazzo
ragazzi mi stanno diventando tutti
itunes ha istituzi cioè non è possibile
salve multiplayer ma cosa multiplayer
no passando dai non ho mai pin di chi a
fai vedere che è un fast and furious
migliore di quello originale vai così
ancora la mia vita un quarto incredibile
l'alibi del meglio di fast and furious
ragazzi l'accordo ragazzi facciamo un
paio di miei livelli perché sono belli
di solito fa vj sui palazzi
cosa vuol dire ragazzi cos'è questa roba
prezzo space
mica sono ragazzi mia moglie sa come si
va in moto noi andiamo così molto a
isola ti diverti secondo me si diverte
amore mio non devi più venire in vacanza
con me consumo torino sai che finiamo
così male avevano ormai dovresti
conoscermi come facciamo a striscia la
faccia per terra e non morire
spiegatemelo ho dato una facciata
incredibile ma ok la gamba di mia moglie
cielo a penzoloni ma l'abuso come
portachiavi mediche funziona come
portachiavi anche bello salto col tavolo
aggrappati al tavole tenenti forte fa vi
va bene non c'è più il tavolo non c'è
più cazzo non c'è non ci sono manco più
io a chi che fossili ragazzi ma perché
fa queste cose se la mia vita e
completano ma metti cielo qualche
traguardo ste cose
quindi ragazzi conclude l'episodio spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto è sempre
bello tornare sulle primis vedere che
non è cambiato niente perché è la mia
vita torna ad avere un senso quindi
ragazzi spero che ha visto vi sia
piaciuto alcove seguito seguito è
piaciuto lasciato momento mi piace anche
a faccia di facebook e come vi trovate
nelle stazioni sono state ridisegnate
per i civili e ora prossimo bello
ragazzi